we have a guest we do have a guest we do
have a guest we do have a guest and
merch why don't we introduce our guests
uh ladies and gentlemen host the
American Journal Master of the blade and
our brochacho Mr Gusto Montgomery
himself Harrison Smith ladies and
gentlemen Harrison Smith baby what's up
man
not too much thanks for having me on
fellas how are y'all doing you know
you're welcome whatever you want on this
show uh thank you for coming on um Dan
every time we have you on something just
bad are we just becoming like a bad Omen
we apologize for that the last time we
were on not the the live oh yeah during
the day we were on Owen's show when the
when the Alex verdict came down like I'm
we're really sorry I don't think it's
our fault but we always happen to be you
know somewhere in the Infowars vicinity
it just works out that way sometimes I'm
sort of in the same boat because I was
uh hosting Alex's show on January 6th
today this is how this is how much
trouble Infowars is in Alex wasn't able
to do the first hour of his show because
he was being deposed for a bankruptcy
hearing so when Owen got sentenced I was
once again sitting behind the desk uh at
a on Alex's show so I don't know it just
works out that way sometimes and also I
think Harrison does have the most guest
appearances on ROTC I'm trying to think
of I think he does yeah you're you're
the top one I believe he's our go-to
yeah he's our goat he's our go-to guy
um and I by the way I hope you love that
you the our thumbnail today was you with
the blade which was badass photo I got
to give you credit that was a badass
photo
thank you thank you very much yeah they
said you know it's it's time we update
your head shots and I said all right
just let me bring in a katana don't ask
questions just let me have a sword and
I'll pose with it and I was bringing up
shots from anime being like I want to
look like this I want to look like Mugen
from Samurai shampoo so uh that's what
we did are you out of the bankruptcy
courts like we want that sword he's like
hey I brought that from that from home
Harrison has no time because he's
watching the Netflix live action one
piece it just came out so he's like
really busy you know watching I always
thought you were more of a Euphoria guy
not you know I never watched uh one
piece and also I don't have time to
watch any TV ever anymore so yeah I'm
just just there's no time so yeah like
today you know the we we only we we just
covered it a little bit at the beginning
but Owen got two months in in prison for
we still can't figure out what we're
still trying to figure out what he did
yeah I read the uh the criminal
complaint that said and I quote while he
didn't go in the building he didn't have
to that's literally what he said and I'm
like what so we don't even have to break
the law that we're alleged to have
broken at this because what was it um
like what was it staying in a place on
author I don't know what it is like
trespassing essentially and it was like
but you weren't you wouldn't even in
there
well it has to do with him getting
arrested in 2019 December of 2019 when
he interrupted Jerry Nadler and then he
signed a deferred uh agreement thing but
it's all it's all baloney basically he
had to do community service and he did
his community service they just lied
about that completely in the sentencing
uh but it dates back to that where he
was he basically was restricted from
doing certain things on the capitol for
a certain for four months it was
supposed to be four months the beginning
of 2020 then it got pushed back because
of covid it's all [__] I mean he
literally is being imprisoned for two
months because of his speech like they
don't make any bones about it they're
like here's here his speech I mean I
listed out on Twitter it's like if
they're like he uh he announced he he
said he uh exclaimed he it's like every
synonym for speech that you can imagine
yeah it was for speech and they do they
literally said like he didn't go into
the capital but he didn't need to
because other people inspired by his
rhetoric did go in so that's so what
about where I am Sir Nick Fuentes or you
know I don't know everyone else that
actually said storm the capital
there's a lot of guys that literally
said we're going to storm the capital
and they were on tape and nothing and
not only that I I I think I think with
you know people like all because now
we've had the the luck to like meet a
lot of people in for worse and the one
thing that we've always said is like
these guys aren't [__] grifters who
are just saying stuff because but when
you talk to them like off air would they
say they believe like it's not this is
this isn't like you know what I mean
like some people it's like they they go
with the wind and stuff like that
depending on on what you know what's
happening in the moment of the word so
what's the right thing to see you guys
are very do you believe on air would you
believe off air and it's and it's it's
it's actually I think that's why you
guys infowar specific gets punished so
much it's because you're not gonna you
know change your thoughts like like
Jesse Ventura did with all that stuff
where it's like oh no no no now the vax
is the best thing in the world and uh I
I think you're getting punished just for
being sincere I really believe that like
I I think that's that's a big part of it
because
like I said you read these complaints
and you're like I saw your Tweet too or
it's okay so speech so so speech so so
what you're saying is that words were
said and now he's going even if it's for
a date he's going to jail for it
yeah it's essentially saying that
because he expressed an idea that other
people who did commit violence also
believed he is therefore responsible for
the violence that they committed right
because he questioned the election and
because because the fraudulent election
is why people rioted he is therefore
responsible for the riot like it's it's
completely insane what's happening and I
I really think it has a lot to do with
the fact that Owen and Alex are both
activists like they their whole thing I
mean our the the you know motto of
Infowars is you are the resistance it's
about getting active it's about getting
involved it's about encouraging people
to actually take part and not take it
sitting down and I really think that's
the the real thing they don't like
because they would prefer the you know
you can compare you are the resistance
to trust the plan right the Q Anon just
like just sit back trust the plan don't
do anything for yourself like they
wouldn't care if we just were sitting
back in common uh commentating but it's
the fact that we encourage people to get
involved and especially Alex and no and
are out there with the bullhorn with the
armored truck you know actually doing
things and actually taking it to the
streets they really don't like that it's
the same reason they went out for the
proud boys or The Oath Keepers if you're
actually doing something that's when
they go after you I you know I'm glad
you brought up the The Oath Keepers and
the proud boys I know uh Stuart Rhodes
and like Enrique Tara Joe Biggs got a
really [__] railroaded I I gotta ask
is it is it kind of like I don't know I
feel like this is kind of screwed up but
I feel like the system has me so Buck
broken at this point that when I found
out like Owen was getting two months I
literally went oh thank God like no you
know what I mean instead of like this is
an outrage he only didn't like I just
went okay my man all right two months yo
you'll get through that man you'll get
out all right like because with all this
other [__] going on I'm like oh dude
we've hung out with Owen man that man
could [__] he can go we were partying
on and uh he's just a cool dude and I
was like man I don't want to find out he
gets 17 years or some [__] you know and
it sucks but isn't that the point isn't
the point to make you feel like yeah
that's right no no it's natural to feel
that way because obviously it could be
worse but it they make you feel like oh
my God thank you they're letting him
only get to though he's only gonna go
and then you catch yourself I cop we
both before the show you catch yourself
going like wait this is [__] up it
doesn't matter if it's for a day but in
reality as a person you're like I'm glad
he's not he's they didn't just really
nail him to a cross but it doesn't
matter it sets the president of like you
know like you said you have free speech
until you don't have free speech no
nobody has it anymore we're pretending
that we do no you don't you know my
abscess Free Speech well Ray Epson well
I'm sorry unless you're a government
asset you don't have free speech
yeah no it's uh no you're exactly right
it it does feel that way where it's like
oh thank goodness only to only two
months of his life uh he's gonna be
spinning in a concrete box with a bunch
of like murderers like yeah yeah it's
it's completely unfair but yeah then you
look at the other sentences and I mean
the proud boys is maybe the most
ridiculous
I don't know I mean it's it's varying
levels because on one hand Owen is a
journalist he actually actively
encouraged people not to go into the
capital like did the opposite which if
if they really did think that this was
like almost an Insurrection and that all
the congressmen almost died like they
should be giving medals to Alex Jones
and Owen Shroyer for using their
influence because they easily I mean
they could have gone up and gone we're
good Now's the Time we're gonna get him
you get in there and don't leave until
you know they could have done that and
people would have listened and it would
have been way worse if they had instead
they used their influence they used
their uh you know the respect they have
from the crowd that was there to say
don't go in the capital God only knows
how many people in that crowd they saved
if they convinced one person to not go
in the capital that one person you know
is uh is free now because they listen to
him so it's it's varying degree so Owen
is a journalist who they are literally
putting in jail because of what he said
on his show questioning the election or
even five months after January 6th like
they actually quote in the sentencing
memo a show on Infowars from May 21st
where Owen says like I think the quote
he said was like it's like a mouse Roars
like it basically was saying January 6
was nothing compared to what black lives
matter and antifa did so they're taking
quotes from his program from five months
after the event and using that as
evidence of why he should go to prison
that's terrifying but then with the
proud boys you have an unspoken
conspiracy they literally got convicted
for conspiracy despite the court and
everybody acknowledging that there was
no communication no plan tario was in
prison on the day that it happened so
we're so far gone in this country I
don't even it's like it's not even fun
anymore it's not there's nothing to like
point out this is the difficulty with
being a conspiracy theorist these days
is you used to have to like reveal
things used to have to like expose plans
and do research and figure out what they
were going to do and show people and now
they're just doing it in your face and
I'm just like reading mainstream media
headlines being like
here you go this is what's happening I I
don't have anything to add to this it's
just you either realize how [__] up
all this is or not and that's it that's
a good point like you don't have to go
behind this like you know break it down
anymore they're doing it to you and
they're laughing at you like they really
are and I'm not saying that people say
but they really are they're laughing at
you because they know they could get
away with it because they've taken
control of all the points of power
including social media including
corporations they've controlled
everything so it's it's what what do you
do and it's like I I tweeted this out
earlier today it's like I'm waiting for
one [__] Republic when high ranking a
public and official Republican official
to come out and fight and see what
they're doing Owen is wrong it's [__]
[__] you can't do but they're not
going to do that because they they talk
about Free Speech when it's convenient
just like all these Republicans are like
oh yeah the covet thing was a mess but
during covet we remember you were a lot
of you people now that are talking about
a battle was where get the shot everyone
go get it it's the best thing in the
world it's they they it's no there's no
the sad part is when you look back is
there is nobody who's fighting for you
who's fighting for you they're going to
do a committee for an inquiry of another
Committee of maybe they'll impeach Biden
come on
yeah no it's you're exactly right I mean
the Republicans are like worse than the
Democrats I know it's kind of a cliche
talking point but it really is true that
like they are I don't they're like
scared little puppy like I picture the
Republicans I just picture like a dog
that's been beaten so much it's just
like pissing itself in the corner
shaking just like scared to to speak out
and it's just like what do you have to
lose they smear you on everything anyway
they already call you Nazis and whatever
why would you not stand up for somebody
like Owen Shroyer who did nothing wrong
it's provable they did nothing wrong I
mean these people don't do anything
that's not pre-approved by some PR uh
you know controller that that doesn't
have America's best interest in mind
certainly it's nuts it's infuriating man
I I honestly don't know where we go from
from here I actually think it's worse
than that I don't think they're scared
they're afraid and I don't think they're
scared at all I think they [__]
despise us just as much as Democrats do
it's just yeah no actually it's not it's
not like why aren't you going out there
fighting for the little man and doing
your job oh no we're doing our job we're
working with them to [__] rape your
family's future I thought were you not
aware of this yeah I'm not afraid to
speak up for you I want you dead
now we see we've we've transferred from
Republicans we're the party that
conceded and and gave up with dignity
right acting like we are just Statesmen
coming to a compromise where we give up
everything we want they get everything
they get but this is how politics work
it's give and take to like they still
lose at everything but now they just are
petulant and whine about it and complain
they've gone from losing with dignity
and some semblance of statesmanship to
losing and whining and being a [__]
about it so it's just we've been
downgraded in every possible way but we
gotta own the libs bro right and it's
it's exactly it's it's these little
fights that we have over dumb stuff and
people sharing like you know fake click
bait stuff online where you're like this
[__] doesn't [__] matter none of this
matters like like in the the like we've
been pointing out on the show and I know
you have and everybody in Fort Worth has
to doing it in your face now they're
doing it in your face and they're saying
what are you gonna do about it and the
answer is nothing why because if you try
you're gonna go to jail for two months
if you try you're going to lose you're
going to lose your job if you try
they're going to do what they did to
Madison Coughlin who came out and goes
hey they invited me to a gay orgy and
then they're like oh look at all these
tapes we found of him we better get rid
of him and they did and they and they
did because you you step out of line
they will do everything to destroy you
they're calling Elon Musk by the way I
I'm on the fence still about this guy
but they're calling him a traitor
because he wouldn't turn on starlink for
Ukraine because they wanted to kill
civilians it's like get you know they
will will control and you know what just
now we saw Holly talking at the
beginning of the show about you know the
the government was going to Twitter and
telling them to censor stuff and this
and that I'm like that's great I hate I
don't care what are we gonna do about it
like I love hearing what they did but at
the end nobody does anything about it
McCarthy's gonna be in there Mitch
McConnell's corpse is going to be in
there and they're going to control all
the points of power and nobody really
has power look what they're doing look
whether you like Trump or don't like
Trump right look what they're doing to
him look what they're doing by the way
that's after he did play their game with
the vaccine he goes look I'm gonna play
the game and even then they were still
like nah no no guess what you're gonna
go to jail too everybody goes to jail
Russia's laughing at us you saw Putin
today come out and go yeah but I don't
want to hear about how bad I am you're
locking up your political opponents
yeah and of course it's not just America
too I don't know if you've seen the
stats where it's like you know the per
000 uh number of people that have been
arrested for speech and it's like uh
Russia 300 uh UK 3 000. like 10 times
more people have been arrested in the UK
for their speech for you know calling a
lesbian a lesbian or something like that
uh then get arrested in in Russia so
yeah I'm I you know I'm I'm looking at
uh Eastern Europe I'm looking no I I
mean I don't want to I don't want to go
anywhere but yeah it's we are utterly
[__] I mean from every angle they're
like taking kids away from parents for
not affirming transgenderism the borders
are open Crime is out of control they're
Prosecuting their you know former or
their uh you know primary political
opponents it's just all out in the open
now so it's it's actually it turns out
it's way harder
it's way harder to get people to care
like now everything's out in the open it
was easy before when everything was
hidden and we could go look look at
what's happening you know nobody knows
this now everybody knows it and we go
don't don't you care don't you care this
is happening and nobody gives a [__]
it's it's like watching a Shyamalan
movie when you already know the twist at
the beginning and there's a lot it
doesn't matter they're doing it right
they're saying we're doing this we're
going to take your children away New
Mexico New Mexico got she got so [__]
cocky so fast that even even Democrats
were like we're gonna cost the seats
calm down because look they believe it
all these all these accounts that were
simultaneously like Ted Lou and [__]
David Hogg they were coming out and
being like this is unconstitutional they
would take your guns away in a heartbeat
but this was the the Democratic talking
points came out and they were the
Democrats talking points came out like
look she's gonna cost the seats we
wanted to do this but we weren't ready
for that yet we have to wait till after
the election and then we're gonna do it
but she she jumped the gun thinking she
was going to be a hero and now they hate
her too but and by the way look the good
news is the sheriff's over there already
said we're not enforcing it but it but
but it's to the point now where a a
billionaire who invented elect who who
runs an electric car company and local
sheriffs are the only thing keeping your
freedoms when it should be the
Constitution and like that's the problem
like these are the points of failure two
people got two people die or get
replaced and the whole everything falls
apart like this is a this is a house of
cards in a [__] Windstorm and I don't
know what we're gonna do
yeah you know the uh you know what the
set with the New Mexico Governor reminds
me of it's like that scene in The
Sopranos when um uh Chris comes in with
a bunch of watches and he's like yeah
the uh the FedEx truck was open right
there I just I just snagged him the guy
wasn't around and Tony's like you
[__] idiot that's a federal crime
that's that's messing with the mail you
want to get us all busted it's not that
they're against stealing it's not that
they're against you know uh getting rid
of guns it's just you can't be so
obvious with it you got to be more
careful when we're pulling these scans
that's that's uh that's it they truck in
yeah yeah exactly I will say going back
to your point too about like I've
jokingly said too about like you know
Eastern Europe Russia ain't looking so
bad right now but you know somebody
recently on Twitter said like we need to
you know America is a dead country and
we need to get out of here and we all
need to go find some place to settle and
I'm like and bring my guns where because
there's nowhere on the planet you can
take your guns
well you might not need them as much in
Hungary I don't know there's not a lot
of what what was it a mysterious
gentleman uh what's what's the latest uh
euphemism we're using these days oh uh
what are we talking about random guys is
another random guys
random guys in uh in Hungary but yeah I
mean I still man I'm one of those people
I don't give a [__] how utopian your
Society is I want a [__] gun all
right I gotta have a gun I don't give a
[__] if the crime rate is zero percent
or a hundred percent I want to have at
least an equalizer no no you know good
the sad part is that there's like so
many millions
if this was like a risk game this is the
you know risk it's like we've got enough
players we've got enough people we've
got enough Patriots it's just they're so
spread out they're all across the map
like if I could wave a magic wand and
force everybody to move to Florida or
Texas then we would have those it would
be Rock Solid but instead we've got tens
of millions of patriotic Americans All
Surrounded and outnumbered by the
hundreds of millions of Democrats that
control the cities and then therefore
control the states rig the election so
it's it's frustrating because it's just
a matter of uh of like consolidation
that we have the power to do it we're
just so we're just spread too thin well
and then that that's the other thing
that cut would happen with covet was it
it you you know they they make it so you
have to live near the big cities to have
a job now especially after covid when
they shut down all the small businesses
and if you want a job it has to be an
Amazon warehouse now or something or or
any place that's near a big city because
they took that away from you too they
they let the corporate that's why the
corporations play games you know and I
you know you look back and obviously
hindsight's 2020 but like you know we
were always like you know corporations
are you know capitalism cat and we
didn't realize what was happening right
in front of our eyes it's like this
isn't capitalism this isn't this isn't
what this is four companies running the
world is in capitalism you know and and
and we let it and honestly we we let it
I think after 9 11 we got so patriotic
you know that we thought man look at
look coming together and then every and
then we're like you know we were
defending these I remember not too long
ago we were defending Budweiser we were
defending these corporations be like
they're private company they could do
whatever they want and now they're like
what they want to do is cut your kids
dicks off and you're like whoa whoa wait
a second what happened yeah the problem
is is he went it's a private company
they could do what they want and then
Twitter came to us and went so the
government told us that we want to
censor you so yeah yeah and that's I
mean right it's a good point they circum
they circumvent the limitations of the
Constitution by Outsourcing it to
Corporation I mean that's what
stakeholder capitalism is right this is
what the world economic Forum was
created to uh to bring about and yeah
you're exactly right I mean
you know there's an interesting uh twist
in this that like you've got these it's
almost like the only corporations that
are still American are the defense
companies because legally like they have
to hire American they can't Outsource
because you know you it's it's National
Security so they have to hire Americans
so it's this weird thing where like it's
the defense companies that have gotten
into all these like insane Wars that
have destroyed us but now that that
process has happened they're like the
only companies that are actually still
American and actually maintain some
vague sense of patriotism and may
actually save us somehow like it's very
weird everything is backwards and it
does it all traces back to 9 11. I mean
you know obviously it's the anniversary
and I sort of hate like treating 911
like some sort of holiday or like uh
it's weird it's like it's be like
celebrating Pearl Harbor day if or you
know memorializing Pearl Harbor day if
like we never actually went to war with
Japan it's just like this memory of the
time that we were attacked and didn't do
[__] about it and ruin our own country
as a consequence of it so I don't even
like but it is a good time to go back
and go man do you remember the world
before do you remember how everything
the security theater the uh Homeland
Security Now the Patriot Act that's
being turned against Americans as we
always knew it would it all goes back to
9 11 and 9 11 was of course an inside
job so I it's uh wait what it's what
first time here hold on this is a new
one for me are you telling me that
burning printer to paper didn't take
down building seven are you telling me
that didn't happen
search melting temperature of steel okay
real quick I'm looking it up oh and
Google says I'm on a watch list I am on
a watch list again my new favorite thing
to when people go building seven I'm
like seven that's cute
we're all about building six now boys no
no and it's it's funny because Tom
fitton goes you know after 9 11 we we
did a Freedom of Information Act to get
the Pentagon footage and here showing a
plane hitting and all the replies were
like this is stuff that white people to
give me hope all the replies are like I
don't see a plane what plane there's no
plane there's absolutely no plane
um and it look and it was and it's it's
not even like we talked about this I
think last time you're on too but it's
what they do is now this is one of my
favorite opposite they do is they throw
in Wild conspiracy theories with actual
provable ones that way everyone looks
crazy they Poison the Well everyone
looks crazy it's brilliant when you
think about it yeah because you're like
I don't know man I got questions about
the intelligence Community is what they
knew the South you're right it was space
reptiles right direct energy weapon
belittle you and make you throw and you
know I I'll be honest with you like you
know you look back a lot of people even
you know even everyone was so patriotic
back then that everyone's like yeah you
know you know we can you know Buck these
guys we're gonna [__] turn them into
glass and everyone's and then you don't
realize what we were doing was behind
the scenes they were like Patriot Act
Right now we're gonna control you
forever and every president in
perpetuity has resigned it every single
one the same the same the same way they
didn't release the JFK stuff that's
because Pompeo was in like oh we can't
no we're not until Trump not to and he
didn't it's it's we were patriotic
though I remember I specifically
remember buying so many of those little
chinese-made flags and those Indian gas
shops
I called I called french fries Freedom
fries for like two years I did my part
thank you I even called it Freedom onion
soup yeah no it's actually true I called
it Freedom kissing that was me Freedom
kiss that's what I called it no yeah not
but it's uh so much of it but no yeah
you're right and although we'll get back
to the direct energy weapon because I I
might I might differ with you there but
yeah that's the and like you know I
haven't obviously I worked for Infowars
I have an open mind I think that all of
these things are possible so I don't
hold it against anybody if they believe
in Flat Earth or you know any of these
things but I am kind of getting sick of
it I am kind of getting sick of like
dealing with real tangible provable in
the mainstream media conspiracies that
are taking place like our rights being
destroyed wars being launched like
human animal hybrids being created like
they're and they are I mean it's insane
and it really is happening and you're
pointing to mainstream media sources and
then you know I post something about 9
11 yesterday saying like you know the
big difference between now and 2001 is
that back in 2001 they had to actually
fly a plane into a building to start a
war now they just like announce they're
just like oh we we've been at war did we
not did we forget to tell you sorry yeah
we've been at War for a while now hey
boys new war just dropped yeah yeah they
don't even like bother like pretending
that you know it's under the ndaa or
anything they just do it and like tell
you afterwards or you know taking your
your freedoms through the Patriot Act
it's like with kovid they were just like
trust us covet exists now give up all of
your rights like no proof necessary and
I got all these responses being like
Plains Harrison it was CGI please I
thought you of all people and it's like
can we just can we just focus on the
stuff that like we know for sure is
[__] up and not go down the crazy
rabbit holes it's it's really
counterproductive honestly I I will
concede I don't I I just want to say
it's not that I don't believe direct
energy weapons don't exist right like I
do believe they have they could probably
call some fingers of God right from a
goddamn satellite if they want to my
point is is that everybody wants to
overuse that now to the point where
people aren't even going to believe
those exist and it's like look if I want
to burn down a bunch of [__] you know
places in California or Hawaii
especially the California wildfires
they're always like Direct Energy weapon
I'm like bro California is always
begging to go up like a Tinder Box like
seriously you could have a mouse could
go in the redwood forest and fart the
wrong way and the whole Forest is going
to burn down I'm just saying do I think
they exist short but it's a lot harder
to call Giant [__] laser beam down
from space than they're just you know
covertly set some fires which I do
believe they do you know what I mean
yeah but I mean the thing with like the
the Hawaii one I mean do you remember in
January they caught on video like
Chinese satellites beaming lasers down
onto Hawaii like nobody it it's just
it's funny
yes yeah yeah they were they were no
actually what it was was they were
measuring the atmosphere to study
climate change so because because you
know because you know China is really
big into climate change so yeah of
course that makes sense obviously right
on oh yeah on one hand they're literally
like depopulating the oceans of fish but
on the other hand they're launching
satellites to measure the carbon
production now it's all ridiculous but
it's not like we caught their spy
balloons okay get out of here I know
well that's the other thing is like yeah
it doesn't mean necessarily that America
used uh direct energy weapons on itself
like is China not kind of our enemy are
they not kind of constantly [__] with
us and trying to do things in an
underhanded secretive destructive way
like is this really so far outside of
the realm of possibility especially I
it's just funny to me that like it's
2023 and people go lasers from
satellites yeah right some sci-fi
fantasy it's like and then you go to
just the military website and they're
just like please let us show you the
vast array of satellite bounded lasers
that we have operational at this moment
here's how they work and here's what
they do it's like nobody who actually
works in these fields thinks this is
crazy and Beyond uh possibility it's
like it's 2023 there are space lasers in
orbit right now you can go check the the
military sites themselves they brag
about it so it's just funny to me that
people act like that so out of the realm
of possibility no but you know it's in I
at this point when you say I honestly
think that when you said with the gov I
would whenever something happens now and
this sucks because that I've gotten this
way I always go did our gov my first
culprit in my head's always like our
government and that you know not for
anything else but because you get burned
so many times that you're like okay did
we do this again because you know [__]
the cool in Ukraine I mean the all the
stuff that people get caught doing all
the time and you meet my mind
immediately goes to who does this
benefit who did this in the government
at worst our government did it okay at
best we had information they had
information about it and did nothing
which I think is a lot of stuff I think
there's a lot of going back to 911 but I
think there's a lot of stuff where we
know what we know bad stuff's gonna
happen how many not many of the shooters
were known to the FBI how many and
that's not one or two we're talking
about a lot right we're known to the FBI
there were this and that but then but
those guys were out on the streets
roaming there but God forbid you were
January sixth three years in a in
solitary confinement
yeah and I think they found Joe Biggs
passport outside of tower one oh that's
what it was yeah yeah that's what it was
yeah yeah that was convenient huh just
an hour later like hey I found Muhammad
atta's passport it's right here wow so
melted steel beams but not passports
okay that's uh you know that's what uh
things are just things are so different
now can you imagine that being believed
now like I I I can't buy it they it's
it's completely insane but we were
gullible we were gullible I mean we were
gullible because we we especially back
then the internet was kind of in its
infancy right so you didn't have any you
didn't have anybody I remember this this
is this is a true story I remember
looking back I thought he was crazy but
now I'm I go man this guy poor guy was
tortured I was in Community College
after 9 11 that I dropped out of and I
uh went there and I remember we had an
uh it was an economies class
and the guy after 9 11 like I'm talking
about two weeks after 9 11. walked in
with like a stack of papers that he had
printed out you could tell you print it
out and he was like not about a condom
or anything that goes we did this 911
was us this bush knew about it and this
and we're all like ah you're crazy you
big crazy and you could tell the guy was
panicked he was like no I'm telling you
he did it and he explained now looking
back a lot of stuff that a lot of good
points right about Cheney and about the
connections and about revenge for George
W for George Bush Senior and he sat
there to the point where they complained
that he had to give us all A's or he's
going to lose his job which that was
nice but I look back and I go wow back
then that was the crazy dude that nobody
listened to and you look you look back
and you go we should have listened to
these people you know
yeah well I I was one of those crazy
people and I think it's so funny that
like uh my my dad in particular you know
it went from like high school me being
like come on dad jet fuel doesn't melt
steel beams and then like you fast
forward a decade your dad finds out
about Q Anon and suddenly you're the one
going all right buddy let's uh let's
pump the brakes here it's uh there's not
actually kids in the pizza basement
let's let's chill out on it it's like
you said though I mean that the whole
idea of trust the plan is like that
should be a [__] red flag immediately
when you're doing it like that
I don't know how anybody fell for that
but now look at look at the Nordstrom
pipeline explosion like does anybody in
the world think that that wasn't America
or wasn't Ukraine so think about what
that entails that's like had to be at
least dozens possibly hundreds of people
involved keeping it totally secret it
was a massively destructive terrorist
attack that was like the worst
ecological disaster of all time it was
damaging a major allies crucial
infrastructure while flirting with war
with uh you know an Undeclared enemy in
Russia like think about what it entails
that we blew up the Nordstrom Pipeline
and realize nothing is beyond the payoff
for these people there's nothing that's
like too extreme or too far or too you
know uh
unbelievable for them to pull off they
are literally doing it right in front of
our faces with the Nordstrom Pipeline
and then they lie to you and tell you no
Russia did it themself you know Russia
did they blew up their own Pipeline and
then they just laugh at you well well
the Polish uh you know Minister tweets
out like thank you USA I mean it's
ridiculous dude I don't even believe
Putin killed percocian just how did that
I mean I could be wrong that's just my
gut tells me I'm like I don't buy it I
don't believe it it's but that's what
you are you've become so but they made
us all skeptical every time something
happens I don't believe it anymore like
I've thought and that's my default is
not believing the official story because
all they do is lie like you said the
pipeline's a great example if they did
it and then when they were asked did you
guys do it they're like nah nah it was
Russia and then you're like why would
Russia blow up their own Pipeline and
then we had that we had to believe that
he was just a crazy evil Maniac who was
what no my my relationship with my
government is so irreparably damaged
it's just like a check that you had in
your life that you give a million
chances to and now like now the
government can just go hey you know what
let's catch up you want to grab some
lunch and you're like why why no why
yeah I don't know yeah that's cool they
come out like uh official pronounce it
the sky is blue and you're just like
[__] no it's not [__] I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go check this out for
myself I think it's a you know once you
sort of get used to to thinking that way
it's not actually that bad I feel bad
for the people that are just now
starting to think this way my mom the
other day when I was showing her some
like AI stuff just like how you can
create AI voices because uh you know
this guy chase at Infowars now is like
doing all this AI stuff where they are
putting our faces on on movies and like
taking my voice and having me read
things out it sounds just like me but
it's not me my mom's like I just I can't
trust anything anymore and I was kind of
like wait you trusted things before this
you actually yeah from the beginning
your your position should be this is
probably [__] let me you know have
it confirmed before I even entertain
this idea and that's not actually an
unhealthy way to live if when you're
when it's shown to be accurate you can
then you know say okay that's what this
is that's what this is like you can't
just think everything's fake all the
time everyone's a Fed everyone's
compromised everything is an illusion
The World is Flat like that's unhealthy
I think but uh having having the initial
skepticism is definitely healthy I'll
say this though just going to your point
about the sky being blue if the
government told me the sky was blue it
wouldn't be enough for me to go outside
and look if I went outside and saw the
sky as blue I would go to a doctor and
be like there's something [__] wrong
with my eyes I don't know what's going
on man but the government said the sky's
blew I went out and the [__] sky is
blue so something's [__] do you know
how bad I wanted aliens to be real and
now that the government said aliens are
real I don't believe aliens are real
that's where I'm at now I've done got
completely around yeah I don't believe
they're real and I now I'm to the point
where I don't give a [__] if they are
yeah this is so [__] up yeah dude and
that's that you can just imagine the
globalist sitting in there in their
caves or on some yacht somewhere being
like it's time release the information
about the aliens and then they do and I
just like shut the [__] up nobody cares
like we don't we don't buy it we don't
care you you know who your small IQ and
PC friends were when they started that
that little bluebeam [__] a while back
and like any of your friends and went
wow aliens and you're like we're about
to get into a [__] like legit fight
like a hot war with a [__] nuclear
superpower
no no dude it's true it reminds me of
that uh of it was that episode of The
Simpson the Mr Burns where the where
they're all sitting around like a large
table just deciding yeah just a
republican yes exactly and it's like
that's what it is they're just waiting
to drop the next thing because of how
bad it is and then they have people then
they have people fighting over
um fighting over over dumb [__] like you
know what's what's what's uh what's
what's Andrew take doing and and I'm
like I don't care I don't care about any
of these people the world's on fire like
I don't I don't really I the dumb [__]
that that we're that we're fighting
about that we're complaining about is is
so minuscule you know compared to what's
really happening and and you become
frustrated a lot of people go like man
you guys have got a really black pill
it's like okay it's not that we're not
we don't want to be but it's like you
know we have to joke about literally
everything both sides now because you
sit here and watch the Republicans
talking yeah well that was a great
speech what a great speech he gave you
didn't do anything about it you're still
gonna confirm McCarthy you know what I
mean that's a great who you hate
McCarthy then why'd you vote for him
yeah that's true we all we all just want
to go back to September 10th 2001 play a
little PS2 I'm telling you you know what
I mean relax 99 for me I want to go to
99 I'm happy right there oh yeah that
was a good year like the day after the
Matrix came out perfect hang out there
where you're where your uh leather
jacket and yeah man everything uh
[__] sucks now and uh it's just
getting worse and worse I mean the fact
that we are having to talk about masks
again I want to kill myself what do you
think about that what do you think about
the math thing it's like we we went
through this we won this argument
already I'm not doing it again I'm not
having this argument again I'm not
hashing it out again we've had the
argument we were proven right you all
admitted we were right and now you
expect us to like put on a mask again
and after act like it's ridiculous when
we we just remember the last two years
it's ridiculous that we remember all the
things that we learned but did you not
see did you not see Schumer come out
today and he was like I can't Americans
are worried about more stuff than
impeaching Biden we wouldn't have time
for political Witch Hunt I'm like are
you [__] serious
like it wasn't even that long ago it's
not even shrouded in time where you
forget what happened it's like I
remember this we covered it we remember
you guys doing it and they just thought
she came out trust the science trust the
science you saw him on a recent ones at
CNN or MSNBC where it's like these
there's usually reports are misleading
they're misleading I'm Not Another
Science you wanted us to trust
I see people wearing masks again too I
was gonna bring that up you were showing
me videos at the airport of just I'm
like people are you're doing this again
yeah yeah it's wild like people are
doing it and it's like Floridians for
the most pretty much don't but so we do
have a lot of tourists here and you do
see a lot of morning mask and you're
like what are you doing you really it's
like it's 100 degrees outside what the
[__] are you doing with your life
dude it's Midway it's it's cult
programming like literally the more they
suffer the more they become uh
enthralled by the LIE right it's like
literally a thing with Colts where like
there will be a cult member that's
acting up and they get the [__] beaten
out of them by all the other cult
members like they'll take off their
belts and just like whip them they're
laying on the floor and when they're
done they're like thank you thank you
for teaching me I was so wrong I'll
never mess up again and they actually
like become more enthralled in the in
the cold programming so these people are
like the mask sucks I got hurt because
of the vaccine but like that proves how
dedicated I am to being a good person
it's it's literal cult psychology that
we're dealing with on the on a
civilizational level it's horrifying if
if you're fully boosted now that means
you would have had to have eight shots
eight H I counted eight hours to survive
fast four I mean I don't know I mean I
don't know and then you see people
passing out and they tell you no no it's
we've always had high school kids having
heart attacks on basketball courts like
no we have not I have been around for 40
years I've never seen them no but maybe
like once or twice lifetime where you go
wow that was a freak thing huh who knew
the kid was sick
but yeah and it always and it's like oh
it turns out that he was doing heroin
the night before like there was always a
reason and yeah you can go back to old
uh you know old news stories like that
and and see exactly uh exactly how it
was how it was treated back then because
it is completely unexpected and rare and
has never happened before I mean I but I
knew people that like I had a friend
that was going into Europe and she's
like well you know I uh I'm going to
Europe so I got to get vaccinated so I'm
doing that on Friday so I will be out of
commission on Saturday and it's like so
you know you know that by getting this
vaccine you are going to be like
immobile you're going to be immobilized
you're going to be so injured and sick
from this vaccine that you won't be able
to get out of bed but you're going to
get the vaccine anyway I mean how do you
deal with these but what do you tell to
these people to make them wake up I
don't know if it's possible what do you
what we talk about in the shovel what do
you think about about I think a big a
big thing that would help is if Trump if
Trump were to stop stop being so
arrogant and say look man they've I
[__] up they pushed me to do this this
thing is bad but you know I think
Trump's still defending it doesn't help
either you know that that's that's the
part where we're Trump for us like that
really that that was a gut shot because
you're like oh wait a second it's one
thing look not that you should have
because we're we're skeptical people
right but it's one thing that at the
beginning when all this is happening to
rush it up but like to still be
defending it is super weird to me why
are you still defending it it's okay to
take the L on this as a matter of fact I
think more people would respect you if
you did
yeah I think uh I think there's a
a bunch of different things to go into
this obviously and like
I mean I think the thing you need to
understand that everybody needs to
understand and we all sort of do is that
like the entire covid pandemic the
response everything about it was an
attack on Trump so I I don't even think
it's fair to like criticize somebody who
I mean think about it because I went
back and I looked at the day that event
201 was happening right where the the
tabletop exercise where they planned
everything out and I just it was October
18 2019 so I just typed that into the
way back machine went to like the CNN
headlines and it's like Trump
impeachment heats up shocking New
Revelations and it's like stuff I'd
forgotten even happened but it's like
he's being hammered for this meanwhile
the economy is higher than it's ever
been the stock market is setting record
after record he's in the middle of a of
a trade war with China and China's like
literally the headline is like China's
economy shrinks to the lowest level
since 1990 like he was having massive
success he's being attacked with the
impeachment over Ukraine which of course
we all you know it's another Rabbit Hole
to go down and at that same time
secretly in a a little room in New York
somewhere it's the leadership of China
and the U.N and Avril Haynes who's now
the dni the Director of National
Intelligence the head of all of the
intelligence agencies she's the one
running the whole thing it's them
getting together to plan this attack on
Trump and they launched this attack and
it was extremely successful with the
vaccine thing and I've I've talked about
it a bunch I think I I get why he's
doing what he's doing and I don't think
this is why he's doing it but I think it
has the potential to be more positive
than negative is and he sort of did this
you know earlier this week he went on an
interview and was like yeah people are
saying the vaccine's not good and I want
to get to the bottom of it and I think
that's the right move is to go look
people are asking questions about our
wonderful vaccine the vaccine that saved
everybody that I came out with it's
beautiful but people have questions and
I'm I'm a man of the people so I will do
a investigation we'll get to the if we
got if you got scammed I got scammed and
I don't like getting scammed so we're
gonna do an investigation because then
you know they're not going to be able to
say well Trump's just an anti-vaxxer and
this is a completely illegitimate
investigation if he gets elected
president and actually can be pressured
and I think I mean he responds to his
audience if we can pressure him to
investigate the vaccine you don't have
to admit fault Mr Trump you don't have
to go back on anything but just say hey
out of fairness people have questions I
want the answers to these questions too
let's do a full investigation if the
shot wasn't as good as they say it was
then some heads are going to roll and I
think that actually is would be like
better than him becoming an anti-vaxxer
and then doing something like that I
think it's so I think he should hold the
line of where he is and he loves the
vaccine but we'll do an independent
investigation I'll put Robert F Kennedy
Junior at the head of it he'll get to
the bottom of things and we'll abide by
whatever they come up with maybe it's a
maybe it's a pipe dream but I feel like
that could be uh that could be a good
way that he could you know reverse his
fortunes on that because I know a lot of
people hate Trump because the the
vaccine thing I don't think it's that
big of a deal I think I understand his
reasons for doing it I do I think it's
I'll tell you why I think it's a big
deal because my super Republican family
members that because Trump said it was
safe went and took it and one of them
died I mean so it is a big deal I mean I
hear what you're saying in one way but
on the other side it is a big deal to me
it's a big deal to a lot of people Maga
hat wearing family members were like
well I trust Trump so you could play
five D's chess but I don't want to play
it at the cost of people's lives and
that's the part where we're that pissed
that pissed me off more than anything
look I understand that you want to play
5D chess with politics or with China and
all this [__] I get it man you got to
play the game I got it but he took a
really really long time even now just to
say I'm gonna study it study what like
there's nothing to study like either
either I I could admit again I
understand Trump's arrogance is is a big
part of of I understand that's what
makes him great in certain things but
it's also the the blinders that he puts
on and and and when when it starts
affecting people's lives when people are
[__] dying that's where we were like
no no no [__] off now because you know
but you have people going like well if
Trump says it's safe old people listen
to him they listen to me they don't get
they're not us they don't know the 5D
chess is happening they just think oh
Trump says it's safe I'm gonna go get it
then their heart explodes
yeah yeah no no for real no but to be
clear I don't think I think the Trump
was sincere like I think that Trump
still has kind of this like Boomer like
Elite Class mentality where like he sees
all of his friends doing like taking the
shot and giving it to their kids so he's
sitting there like of course of course
the vaccine's good you know why why are
my good friends giving it to their
children if it's not good I don't think
he was playing 5D chess going I know the
vaccine is bad but I'm gonna say it's
good to to play the I don't think he's
doing that I think he sincerely thought
the vaccine was good and thinks it's
awesome and is very proud of it I don't
think that's uh I don't think that's
that's five maybe five D chest thing
he's just a [__] idiot which doesn't
really make you inspire hope in me
either right that's I'm just glad we're
not going to lose our governor I'm so
glad our governor can't [__] yeah he
can't smile yes he can't smile so we're
going to keep a governor thank God for
that but but it but it's I understand
this I know it's a trust listen no one's
no it's no one's sadder than us but okay
trust me no one's sadder than us he man
kill this [__] career man that was a
Howard Dean moment yeah yeah I mean the
whole thing I mean it was bad but let's
be honest the announcement of his
campaign was bad I mean all of it was
bad we're just so if he if he had just
Ben Trump's dude he could have been I
mean in four years he's president for
two terms like he'd just been a little
patient he the world was his but he had
to try to he had to try to go against uh
Trump and that was that was a dumb thing
I mean Ron was that friend that had a
few too many beers at the bar and you're
like dude you could totally kick that
[__] guy's ass you think so yeah
bro it's all glamor muscles all right
yeah I'm a little kick his [__] ass
you're like dude he's gonna get killed
no I know look it's Jeb Bush pumping him
up in the background rubbing his
shoulders you got this champ don't worry
about it for us and obviously we were
pretty pretty hardcore to Santa's
supporter specifically because I what I
mentioned with Trump in the backs and
Julian Assange and the JFK thing and the
fact that DeSantis did what you just
said you admitted Trump can't do which
is yeah I admit I was wrong I was
listening to everybody else and it turns
out everybody else is [__] so we're
opening it back up so so so so so he was
but then when he comes out and his his
goals are are like we're gonna fight
anti-Semitism in Guam and I'm like
[__] what we're gonna drone strike
Mexico yeah but why wait a second what
you're doing [__] what now and again
same reason I don't like the Vivid guy
that Vivid guys look for me that Vivid
guy is says all the right things but if
you're not gonna win and never have to
do anything you could say whatever you
want you could promise the world and
that's how I am with him if it's like
talking to the Zoomers and he's like
yeah we need to get out there kids and
you know break up the banks we're gonna
you know get some real Equity out there
and he's like talking about black church
and he's like we need to outlaw white
folks y'all like whatever what happens
like a guy acts like like the internet
doesn't exist right right he acts like
cameras and the internet don't exists so
he's another but look that's my thing
it's like and if they let Trump run then
we'll see what happens and also like
they stole the election once why won't
they do it again like it's like if we
always joke on the show like all we got
to do is vote harder you're not voting
hard enough yeah nor do we have how far
do you think get out of this situation
we were all pretty stressed out I voted
pretty hard yeah yeah it turns out every
single one of us has to drop off a mail
bag of ten thousand votes in Detroit and
then it's uh we're walking apart you
forget about the P you forget about the
pizza boxes that were fortifying the
elections that they had the cover of the
course and that's [__] I got up in
the daytime for that he doesn't get up
in the daytime no one's listen you know
merch I know he's never been on my show
Once no he won't do it he won't wake up
no no no he can't come American Journal
I can't do it if I stay up which means
you'll be drunk
by the way again thank you for having us
on your show when up there man that was
that was a lot of fun you are a gem of a
man you really are thank you oh please
no you guys are you guys are killing it
is this the first time I've been on your
Rumble Street I don't think I've been on
that wrong but I'm just looking at those
numbers now like totally killing it man
um y'all
as soon as we went to rumble we got on
Shadow band and people actually found us
and that's all it took and we've been
doing really well over here we told
Rumble from day one when we when we were
with them like you know because they
were like well what can we do to like
you know work with you guys and we're
like we need you to do what YouTube
couldn't do just get the [__] leave us
alone just get out of our way let us all
let us run our thing and we'll be fine
stop throwing objects in front of us and
dumping my pockets and banana peels in
front of us and just let us [__] stop
throwing barrels at us like Donkey Kong
and just let us do our so yeah they
kicked us off of you of our YouTube
channel YouTube channel that had 44 000
which by the way would it should have
had hundreds of thousands but we got
completely Shadow banned once we after
the the Crowder uh adpocalypse thing
happened when that Mazda guy decided no
one on YouTube was allowed to make money
so we got we stopped there so it was but
but they took that channel in the and
the final nail in the coffin and it'll
be something that I tell people all the
time the last strike we ever got was for
cyber bullying Jeffrey Epstein and I was
like you could there's not another way
to be taken off this site rest in peace
sweet prince yeah sorry about that so
that was what they did for a
four-year-old video where we were
talking about and I already listened to
it by the way it literally was just us
making fun of Jeffrey Epstein so he's a
protected class you know it's sexual
minorities racial minorities Mossad
agents uh you know uh whatever else and
he's like and he's like three of them
protected and he's like three exactly
he's a bunch of he checks off a lot of
lists and also that weird painting of
Bill Clinton address that no money
people talk about that they should be
talking about right and George W bush
holding airplanes you know you're right
you know I got he was an art connoisseur
do you think out of all the hundreds of
people that went to Epstein Island do
you think there was at least one guy who
was just there for the zip line yeah and
otherwise there was one guy that was
here there was one guy that just really
liked the food there yeah the food and
the zip line yeah you're right there was
probably one guy that was just like no
no I don't want to do anything with kids
she's just it's a free trip to the
Bahamas you know I'm not gonna say no
you know
that'd be a good skit actually the one
normal guy on Epstein Island he just
says completely oblivious he's just
having a great time behind him there's
just like a guy in a devil mask just
like sacrificing a woman he's just like
this Sunset is incredible and then he's
at the buffet like this beautiful place
Virgin Islands beautiful is this bacon
wrapped shrimp this is so good and I
know they're doing spare cooking and
they're eating something if you know
what if SNL had balls I swear to God of
Sno headboard it would be funny if the
premise is just that they're all in on
just not letting him in on it yeah
exactly just let him Pretend We're just
all of their masseuses are like 14 year
old girls and his it's just like a big
Russian woman yeah
it's like a 60 year old Japanese guy and
you're like okay it's gonna be a good
one don't forget Matt Green and Creator
The Simpsons got a foot rub by the
underage girl on an airplane on the way
to Epstein island people forgot that but
that's a real thing
uh it's all real it's six o'clock
Harrison thank you so much for being
honest the great Harrison Smith folks a
wonderful Patriot good guy terrific guy
elephant Folks at Infowars I'll never
say that in public well I still have a
campaign
hey Harrison
thank you fellas very much it's it's
always pleasure anytime
she's accidentally you know go on the
other side of the world and we have some
sort of clock alignment uh your hours
ahead I'm hours behind whatever it is
love to have you guys
by the way go to defendone.com to defend
uh my co-worker who's being sent to
prison for for two years defend owen.com
or go to VINELink and look up Shroyer
come on you're gonna put money in his
commissary put some money on his books
all right my man's got to eat while he's
in there I I did said I did send him a
text message today I said you don't have
to reply I'm sure you're getting a bunch
of these bro but we got you back because
all you guys over there have have been
everybody over there Alex you oh and
everybody rob everyone behind the scene
has been just been so good to us over
there and we really do appreciate that
so you've you've been you've been the
ones that have been real with us so I
hope Ellen comes back like like Dominic
Mysterio and he just really plays it up
yeah oh my God if I were Owen from now
off when I was in federal prison you
know when I was in prison
that's yeah that should be his thing
that should be when I got back from Khan
College he should just start talking
like a [__] convict and remember oh
and you only do two days a day you go in
and the day you get out come out yeah
but no but seriously man but the defense
you said defend owen.com is that correct
I think defend owen.com is the one to go
to for now okay go over there and
Benjamin no no no no no no no
do not go to
Arya
.com
bertaria.org scam uh
guys I need your money too same
difference
I live in Idaho that's pretty pretty I'm
with my wife and kids all day that's
like prison
but it probably is like prison for him
yeah
it's like I used to get the [__] out of
the house for a couple hours a day yeah
right put on a suit and go do something
oh man thank you again man I really
appreciate you coming on and of course
you're welcome on and yeah you're the
all-time uh leader and the guest we've
had on the most so I don't know if
that's good or bad it should be bad it
might be embarrassing for you I don't
know and by the way thank you Miami MILF
posted the link in the chat yeah there
it is there it is booms give send go.com
there you go all right man take it easy
dude we really appreciate it all right
y'all too thank you so much later